a Udacity we just released a new feature
text tada you'll be able to start seeing
reading morsels show up inside your
courses but don't worry we aren't gonna
make you read a novel or a textbook but
sometimes it's useful to leave text for
you like you might see github
instructions or a project rubric inside
a reading morsel but the Udacity
classroom isn't too large we only have
this much space to work with so instead
of forcing everything to move down we
use an overflow to make sure that texts
can scroll you've probably seen
something like this on other websites
let's see what this looks like in CSS I
will right-click here go to inspect
element inside dev tools we can see that
the text on the screen has this CSS
class for overflow:auto within the
Reading area class if we uncheck it
let's see what happens I'll click it and
make dev tools disappear we can see that
the text is flowing outside of the
classroom and into the elements below it
and this is obviously a problem let me
go ahead and turn overflow:auto back on
and everything safely back in here it's
worth keeping overflown mine in the
event that you've got a lot of text you
want to contain in a small area